[Music] I
work Mercado Libre I work with my
internet several years ago
what you know or have heard
is machine lis time I come from that team that
Mercadolibre is an SME dedicated to
machine learning that Mercadolibre
bought a year ago we have been working with
Mercado Libre several years ago  years old so I
have that suit good what I want to
tell you
a little about something related to a
development that we have been doing for
about a year I want to open
the kitchen a little bit about how we are
making life easier for engineers
and data scientists in MercadoLibre
and I am going to have  obviously a
bit from the context of the free market
because I'm just going to be
talking about decisions we make and
these decisions make sense in the
context of the free market
so I would like
any city or anything to go after
any doubt or any challenge that
they want to do me please do it
we are not going to high but the more out of
he
[Music]
well it sounds even better
with little production he said
yes coldly
well with little production he said on the
site because for me today there are many
facilities to do more in the hernán
and the years in general in terms of
technology in terms of  access to
knowledge tutorials
today's computers have a hard time and
suddenly with a few pesos access to the cloud
allows us more and more and everyone
who doesn't know or hasn't
experimented with machine learning raise your hand
although there are few well not so few  but
all of them, well in general, then they
understand that machine learning to
the point of experiencing action cannot
make things easier now of air
putting it 24/7 in a
high-traffic productive system has its challenges for
example setting the timer so that I am not
go time is a challenge
mercadolibre when the free market is
what we call a great ecosystem in
many products many many
business units from  the marketplace shipments
market payment credit is advertising each
one of them is in some way a large
company all grouped together in
distributed work teams and the volume of
free market operations is
truly large in terms
of payment operations what market
payment or shipment can  of packages what market I
send the number of people who enter
our market place some someone of
you ever did not enter the
free market then everything more or less what they
know the volume of traffic that is
generated from the products and
services of  MercadoLibre is monstrous,
that means that we receive a lot
of data, each order, I am afraid, is that
someone visits something, the site
enters and clicks or moves the mouse, it
generates data, so the volume of
data is monstrous, that is why it will go
through the entire  talk because
really, as I was telling you, being a little
test on one's computer
can sometimes be easy, but later
when I continue  If the universe of data
in which you are working is large,
things change, it becomes much more
entertaining, interesting, then having
such a large scale of operations
has forced us to have a strategy
for approaching data science or
machine learning that accompanies that scale.
to move this is still a little
trickling so the strategy that
we are promoting around machine
learning to the free market has different
legs on the one hand the part of dissemination
or education or to ensure that ma jin
learning or expenses in general
cross the different areas  of the
organization, for example, participating in
a pirate event or having thirty to
forty people from the free market come to the
event is part of
strengthening and disseminating the fact that
data science has to be a
normal thing on a day-to-day basis the
technological leg is the  I am going to focus
on this talk and then there is also the
data part, the access and manipulation
of data, everyone must  have some
data problem even in your tutorial
downloading a satellite image or data
at 7 cal they probably reneged
imagine what you renege on with the volume
of data from mercadolibre merkel who
has been going around for 20 years working
collecting things then he has
gone through many technologies he made his
cloud  before the cloud became fashionable
and after our trend he had to
start thinking about whether to move to the cloud
or stay with his infra he started generating
infra when the cloud became fashionable
so I am not going to talk about this in this
track on the problems associated with
data, particularly data manipulation,
although it is interesting, we will talk about it
at another time, it focuses on the question
of technology in the associated part of the
technology that puts us into production
that makes data science or
what  the models or that the experiments
we do end up solving a
business problem for that
MercadoLibre has a
development platform  and operations of web apps
and microservices in a way that abstracts
the cloud so we can work
with either Google Cloud Platform or
Amazon or eventually with other
providers as it has been because experiments are done
the idea is to have an
abstraction layer on top of that  for
the organization to get rid of
and make the best decision from enke
cloud, it is necessary to work fiber is the
habit of the bear
precisely representation and represents
the area and the platform this
free market that allows us to abstract from the
cloud you can think about it as you know what they
are  the box
does not know what the box means
if it is administered that we have been min
good if it is admitted program that is
in charge in the organization that your
things are in production alone in
mercadolibre an oversimplification do
n't hate me the drops the black libre of box
does services they can think no the
teams do not have a the box which
is great for the teams that believe
more in others  other areas and that in some
way we do not deny that part and
we know that it is provided and they look
very good so this platform this
platform that gives us a free market for
these things is dollarized knows
what the latter more or less takes
care of  to make the web application
basically figure and one when you start
the list
I'm going to make an app and that gives you a
repository gives you access to metrics
gives you access to log systems gives you
access to continuous integration
so things are done for that  make
a couple of clicks on the entire repository
and a boiler plate of things 2 care
then in many cases they do not jump and that
we know locker
but good for those that more or less in
addition to the part of the infrabel
behind implies that those containers are raised
and  as I said the cloud is
managed by figure and amazon google cloud
platform and some other mixed options
then specific free market all
that was specialized for a question of
micro service  s of web apps
microservices is for generating an
application that accesses a database or
a cache or a queue business logic
makes decisions returns request many
rest front-end up and res typical
business applications
traditional web development when it started
more and more match in learning people
who do more in learning or data
science in general have other
infrastructure needs
because now we want to train with gpu
or now we want access to
data sources in an easier way and
our machines are not enough for us  but
the same as downloading the data and the
gpu they do not give it to you just like
that, so what we have been working on for almost
a year is what we call hybrid
legal tabs pge is an extension to all
this infrastructure that had no more
free market to do
data science and for those of us who have already been
doing data science in some
way and that I am probably going to try to
reflect problems that  and we all have that
all those who have done at least one
tutorial will have found each other and I
want to tell you well what decisions those of us
who built this extension what kind
of decisions we made or took to
make life easier for us and for the
rest then
for the objectives  what this film has is to
democratize if you want access to
machine learning to the rest of the
organization in facilitating good
practices providing more or less
cured pipelines based on experience and they
know how to transfer knowledge
and it makes a lot of sense to build
infrastructure to be more without giving me
good and  so what did we do
well is it is a framework built in
house or has been done by us for
data processing and machine
learning embedded in fiber well we
did it in house the result of the
consensus of a lot of people and
many teams that already  they were doing
more in learning and others who want to
do more I also feel
that MercadoLibre was coming  ing in a
distributed way but we started to reach
consensus and look for the best
compromise decisions so that it
works for all of us
and this is important because if
we all wanted to agree on
a framework we would all have
ideas and there are many things that we don't  they are going to
appear good and many that are going to look
bad imagine that MercadoLibre is
three thousand developers or three thousand
people associated with the technical and those three
are distributed in all these
business units and these three thousand
people are deploying microservices thousands of
times per day and  of these
three thousand there are several and we want to do more
in learning and we think about how to
do it so
we start to build this based on a
plan that should
be more or less common there should be an
experimentation stage on the data
whatever an extraction stage  of data the
training of a model after
deploying that model that model is put
to live in a place  ar operative to
answer questions and solve a
business problem and eventually
when it is alive monitor it to
make sure that it continues to do
what it has to do and eventually
automate for example I want it to be
retrained every day or all the works
or all  the weeks and things like that this is a
more or less normal pipeline of machine
learning I imagine or at least those of us
who are working outside the
academic part or outside the
experimentation part in a company well it
will be an income first it makes
us solve ourselves  they ask to solve a problem
and then we begin to experiment and
see what the model is what is the form
with the technology that has that sense
of the average that we are shaping and that
the development metrics begin to
close we have to think about solving
well how  I put it on the
client's machine or on the infrastructure it
has
and this is where it becomes interesting
because the cases are my in learning
we will have different infrastructure needs than
the rest
we want to enter with gpu we want to have a
lot of memory to load the data to be
able to compare process it and do something
and generate the data set and we want the
data to be stored in a place
where it can later be accessed to
deliver my  model and to enter the
model now I do want gpu but to
serve I have to see if it is very expensive it is
very expensive they are typical problems that
we have to deploy my inder ning
then well what we built in
broad strokes let me tell you what
years it
does not look
ok  part of the
experimentation laboratories basically what we
did is make lapse available as a
service know twitter twitter lapse
raise your hand
well the idea is that now in fiber and
you have a menu in your application two
or three clicks away if you want a lake that
has gpu  or it doesn't have a slightly
cheaper side and things like that and on the back
a dedicated instance was raised with your
lavorato with your side is  the bird is
secured you have access to your report or
to the data sources it is personal
so no one can work through
you in that lab and you can share
things behind the spare part hours then
from not having this service to having it
does not make life much better  easy for
developers because we all want to
build a la jupiter many times
our machines but when you want to
share with your team you need a
dedicated machine to build the lab
so that everyone can have that service
imagine that if we are hundreds of
equipment like this learning from those hundreds
of  teams each request an instance
no w s to raise one side and ask
the network people to connect the
networks so that they can access the data
and the other owners say they do not have
permission to look like the data so
solve this type of problem  it is what we
did
what they have solved it
is good we all know peter it is the
easiest way to experience that
we have deer  in the talk of another
very interesting tool, you make it
available with a click later
for the tele and training part,
open a tele process or a
training, it is code that we write,
I decide which tlc foot to
connect to a database or a
cluster  from spark or to an ese 3 to
download a down and probably with this
I want to make a data set available
and then train is probably to
grab that data set and eat a model and
do all the fitur engineering and
make a model so we
from infrastructure do not impose
decisions  in terms that if you
want to do it with tenses then with six
interns or whatever we have with
quite simple interfaces in
terms that you have to have certain scripts in
turre why do we allow you well
he composed me differently but you have
some way  if you want to run
join the ntl mail basically if
this branch bus answers me that the price
of telyco watch and run
So a dedicated instance was created with
access to the data,
everything is logged in, there is an auditor and
audit, that is, we can later know who
executed it and what and when, why there must
be such a large organization, we
must be careful, I would like data to come out,
who is consuming  here it is
consuming the resources so this
way we told people to have the
possibility of versioning each
lte run it is versioned then or later
to run to train your model it
does it in relation to a televisa version you
ran here we start to have
the  tracking
if I am going to have a good model when
he trains how and with what data or if it is
or if it is executed on TV which is to
extract a very large amount of data
then
I have to be new they want to
have the same data many times
kind of things are good problems
that what we face on a daily basis
process short data and train 20
models or vice versa I train the same
model with a lot of different data
so far they more or less do so
so well and so it seems to me that very well
since the columbarium clicks lupita
people experience the more or less
the
data manipulation and training code starts to close
cover these bullfights these bullfights and
one can mark them if they are
production ready or not in terms of what
has happened is not true is that one
can define and also for the part
that a little where I want to express myself a
little more what has to do  well
now how do we deploy it like when the
data scientist created his model it can be a
pit lane a site learn or whatever it
generates tensor flow or a directory with
the things that you were from
that is a problem now I need it to
be put in a rest web service  to
start receiving traffic and to
start responding to the problem then
until now even what follows
experience models take off one
version take off another
we for l  apart from
building an image from a model 2 that
responds what state is used then
what we end up doing is that
trained model it is put as part of a
docker image we have a tool
that we build ourselves from
machinery we are using demos looking for
ossobuco that generates
we put something that is very good on the
sheet
as he did not know very well what it was going to be we
replaced his ship whenever he wants
but balsa is in charge of how to
automate the generation of a track
from a model with a bit of
configuration it is especially for this
distinction that the outgoing data
can worry about making the model and
that later with little boiler plate and without
knowing too much about web technologies you
can quickly have a rest api
following that model
and free that we have that plus all the
jury operations everything it has
to do with auto scaling the
cost management audit then quickly
once we have a model with very
few clicks that model is already expressed
as a rest api
answering requests
at the meli scale the medium scale
means that more than we
did to discover from the console
to see if it was already working later that has
to go to a place where it will be
being  executed thousands of times per
second or hundreds of thousands of times per
second well and for all those who have
had to put the
production model they are going to get an idea of ​​the
complexity and what is not
well they have no idea
so again for  generate this to
make this image that I will later
want to deploy as a service
again we gave it that option is that
people say good this model that I
had trained
I want the deployments to determine
infrastructure so we have to give
all the tracking because again  in
terms of operations and corporate
well if the api for brazil stops working tomorrow
the team has to know
why we deploy with what data it will be
quickly  or training
data was broken production was
broken a network problem was broken who deployed
because he had the permissions not having the
permissions the new one came in was wrong
things happen everywhere we have
many new ones all the time I hope to
have many more new cards
and well, all this helps us so that
even the new ones can play more than they
can play calmly knowing that there
are ways to recover and that there is the
infrastructure and that hardly a
finger will break everything well he
says that in time he says that of
time  that I proposed then
I am going to delve into this in that it is the part
that interests me because I work but
I also know of another if you want to ask me
later there are people who build
models in different technologies and
I want it to be an api that I pray in a
problem I want each  Every time a
person goes to see an item, that item, that
page, they will hit a
MercadoLibre service that asks for the
weather forecast of  e delivery to be able to show
on the page that if you buy that
item based on your zip code it will
take so long to arrive it
has to happen to you in milliseconds and the
guys who build that model
did it in tensor flow because they can and
tensor  flow needs a lot of machine and
sometimes fast and sometimes it doesn't depend on the
machine but they don't worry about that
they create the model they deploy it
because it is the best decision and because what works
best then
how do I make that number that that
prediction is execution of that  model in
an online way online means that
the request comes, execute the model, I get the
prediction and return it in the same
flow, well, how do I make it happen
safely and scale, and when
there are 10 rich, it is that a machine reaches
but with size when  up to 1000 if
I need another machine it automatically
looks like another machine or if there are 200 thousand
per minute as we have in this app and
well automatically the 101 are generated  2
machines that are needed, well,
the decisions that we go to us
that those who have this type of
problem may or may not be
useful, but up to which ones he maintains that we talk about
them there, what I put auto sky link
efe of a fire of tap is the way  it is the
app and what the model is serving and
what we leave to these
teams is those of saab and they can only
run their module and not much else that is how
it cannot go out into the world it cannot be
attached directly from saab and you have to
put another  app and figure and traditional
to the front what we know how to do being up
is a sister app where there is
probably I want to implement
business logic sanitization of input
output cache access to services so
when you have to run the model that
predicts the delivery time for a
item that team has to put another
skin in front and this other app and if
you can put it to the world then if they
want to put a cache or if they have to
do what it comes up with  zaró to
inflate with information from other apis
then it appears in the room is a
request for business logic and that at the
infrastructure level in terms of network layer
ficod engine exists web and proxy and
all the things that happen
and by the way we do not know anything good  there are
people from box to service, the
manufacturing people is that these two
applications can communicate very quickly and that they
have a reach but that they are
securitized in terms that the rest
of the world cannot get their hands on it, so
well, mercadolibre is like an ecosystem
of a lot  of microservices that
provide everything you use on a
daily basis,
so, well, some of these
microservices have one of
these applications behind them, which are the ones that
we are providing from the
infrastructure, but in the rest of the
ecosystem it is integrated as it already worked
a little bit  It seems to me a very
interesting decision and he also invited for the
photo I invite you to good here those who
are displaying yes  production systems
does this if you want modularization or
separation of saying just as one separates
their modules and in their codes they separate
what is the input output of the
business logic or things like that
well here to understand that a
bazin learning system can  being a service with
different needs
simply the business logic can
be good to think about it in
separate infrastructures separate repository
separate services things like that
[Music]
good to share a little more in
depth
it seems to
me that I always had caliber before I was in
an SME and  From an SME, I was always
very curious about how the big
companies did to solve their things,
so it seems very valuable to me to
obtain the interest, they will tell me, but to be
able to share with them a little, really
open up, open up the kitchen of how
we do things, because in case
it works then later they will tell me this is
a diagram of one of the parts that I
told him well when I went  If you create a lapse, you
give all this from behind so
that people can click and have
their las, so in this case, in
base issues, we are giving
Amazon, we are using first, we have
to be rose, which it gave, we have our
own api that  it gives a way it makes use of
a lot of open source tools and
a lot of typical
technology and infrastructure tools that
have to make everyone well that
also seems to be important to
share in large companies in
many they use the same thing that we are
using in  the street in the facu in the
SMEs or whatever with more resources you
can do more you can try other
things you can take it to another level but
in general the tools
today are very solid and free software
unlike 15 or so ago  20
years ago that the corporate sphere moved towards
a more private place due
to jealousy and ignorance, today
large companies are using the same
good thing they have more rec  ursos to use it
differently out there but not bad yet it is a
peer service that julián operations
works that abstracts different clouds
and consults a service as if it were
distributed dns standing on the same thing
hachiko is a company that provides these
two services so we do it  what
we do is when someone in fiori says
kirk a lab
we have dedicated clusters to run it
off then an api that what it
says is through standards to an
instance says get up declare this
repo get up jupiter lab and publish 'the
in certain network configuration
quite good people who know about the network
and infrastructure of proxies iberdrola
do this chopin lab internally
through a lot of tools that
we all have access to it decides to upgrade a
computer achieve be repo install the
lab that generates a url through some
network issues  It seems to me that
as a user I click on that url and
I have access to that machine in that
dedicated instance with  On the good side, well,
when I stop using it, but well, let's
see a little bit so that they understand that
what we are using is a little bit
that everyone has access to use and
what
start or what I told I can tell,
I'm sure  specimens other
questions out there don't
almost almost
don't forget
then
this production network and makes this
possibility for data science to have
many facilities to really
experiment and put and solve
real life problems
in a context and in an environment like
free framework is is  deployed as
I told you we began to develop it
almost a year ago to design
approximately a year ago at the beginning this
year we began with the development are
several teams that joined within
MercadoLibre those of us who were machines and
some more man of yours and to start
building  this and begin to deploy
little by little and all the teams that
were doing me machine learning
we began to bring a board first as
beta users  and little by little we were giving him the
assurance that what they can do is
probation red and so that Pablo emigrates,
not so that they look at the
infrastructure of this new one, for
example,
for example, no more children, but there is
a small pib that tells you if a
a user's query is typical
there is stock but there is stock
when they are good and we out there
find that we can
predict the questions and stoke auto
answer them or things like that then well
there is something going on for the moderation people it
's because  example of there
is stock is an app and that responds in 3.5
milliseconds each rich is that it
arrives when it arrives it executes it and
returns it passing through the entire traffic layer
of mercadolibre
in 3.5 milliseconds and today it is
receiving it depends on the moment of the day
between  300 and 1,500 requests per minute
in 300 minutes are quite enough
to use the services in this case
with two instances in a double s I don't know
what type of instances we are going to talk about  ar
is resolved everything is handled
fine now those who are making the
model work with the data they know that they
also have their metrics they do their
tests and then with a few clicks
they access screens where they
monitor this monitor since they are
showing that it is  answering how much
traffic it has how many instances there are at
this moment if they anticipate that there will be a peak
in traffic they can click so that
for a good look it is putting 45
more instances because I know that the
traffic peak is coming and things like that but at the
moment of the  cases where it only receives
detection of fake face items
if I am the official nike store I don't want
there to be juancito selling its official nights
so in terms of business it is very
important to try to predict from
the images for example
if an item is fake not to enter  in
a modeling flow it is good we have
these processes images are doing
tests tests very few scales
we are receiving  receiving up to 10,000 rich people
per minute it is likely renzo I know what it
is for we learn it it multiplies for
days well then this girl is
receiving
one hundred thousand rich people per minute to offer
images so in this case capable with
two instances with gpu it works well but there
may be scaling up to  dozens of
instances 5 a won return figure
because neither
and well there is one of the models that
we have the largest deployed today is that
I told you about predicting the time of
predicting the time of time in which
a package is going to be in the mail
because adding  these times to other
times he is the prediction the
delivery time well then this model if it
is receiving more or less 200 thousand
rich per minutes as before
there were peaks of 300 it has to respond
in less than 10 milliseconds between 5 and 8
for which  they are reaching that
nissan jawbone part realize that already be
thinking in time of three quick
reply 200,000 rich in five
milliseconds  ndos is a spectacular engineering challenge
and it is great that
our attractants do not have this
challenge that we who are
interested in now force us and we can
solve it for them it is great
and that is a development that is
underway we have a lot of things
ahead of us  files that we are thinking about
we are constantly adding to it
we work with development processes
productive thing they see it for me for my
team this is a product so I
my users in this case are the
developers so the prioritization
of the files the the design of the
files from of  demo caption be
testing and I am research and start
integrating solutions for the type
of things we do
we are thinking about it well things are
coming out this week like automation being
able to create TV or create
training for fraud people that every day the
central bank updates their database
of I don't know what so they want
everything  Every morning that table is downloaded, the
score models are entered into
all the users to know a
certain credit risk factor,
then manual operations are carried out, today
I told you that all this
predicts online, so we want to
add a service in which  if one
can already pre-calculate its predictions, it
can be done by putting it in a cache
then really deploying a
prediction cache is a simple task
now we have gpu to train
not yet to serve
this pablo this week I am going to push myself
with that we are already in cost management
different in such a large organization with
so many instances with so many
developers who all have gpu
well the managers will be in charge
of accepting each other it doesn't make sense but it
implies a significant cost cost and
we are working and it will be a
very long-term job in the term  of
monitoring and machine learning metrics
for that we have other talks they want
now colomb  ia among other weeks or they come
from brazil
machine learning system monitoring that is a topic this is a
topic testing and monitoring of the web system
is quite exploited in macy's
landing and other inventions to take into
account
there are some google papers about
what we  we are basing on
specific infrastructure and support the
problem
build infra and then
monitoring tools on that infra to know
if my recommendation model was
broken two weeks ago or not or they are
giving much worse than it had to
be running and that does not mean that
you know the data has to come in every day
more or less to see how the
model is doing, it's great and well there are a
lot of things that are underway and
we're doing
that all thanks
well we'll do a round of questions here
I already have one very quickly
and ask you about the gtl in the topic
of notebooks and in the topic of
registering experiments I would like to
know how I know that technology
But what does it consist of, that is, if they do
their own tests, let's say experiments, or they
also keep a record of
experiments of machine learning metrics,
style that they use with what
parameters, with what seeds, and because
many times what happens is that the one
I do, but under a  novo that in certain
conditions and when that changes and well it
's perfect to
repeat the question why not
from this tool does not rule moses
apart ok but we see the infrastructure
and a flow to run it
if there is an intermediate stage that we
give them of validation then if bosco
regulates  You yourself are also
obliged to write the
control routines for the expected results,
but since there are so many of us and we have
such different flows and work dynamics,
we still do not want to impose one from
this tool now from different
work teams if we have many of our
own definitions  about that
and how this helps us from those
artifacts from the pressing and  of
the control stage how we use them but
well just this week I was chatting
with some of the guys on the
experimentation track at the level
if you are scram we have what we are going for
the scrum track there is an
experimentation track and an
operations track the track  of experimentation
has its own requirements associated with
experimentation as I am going to report that
I am going to make the data that the level
of code in style we are going to reinforce in the
equipment I can program in a notebook or it did
not give me more is defined by equipment and so
through  this allows us to quickly reach
teams that do not have those work dynamics,
to be able to show
them through tools
if you want to model them because we have a
lot of experience there are many guys here
who obviously
in what I do every day
what's up carlos thanks for the talk very
well, I didn't want to ask you, you just
said that all the inferences are made
about the cpu, yes, how do they do it so that in
time they don't know  go very long if you
make inference on the gpu and as a
depression everything with container I wanted to
know if you have control over the
lokeren without it being down so that it uses
those gpu resources and well you can
make the inference a little faster
if in this  this platform and in fiber
in general we do not go out with gpu there are
teams that have
specific needs to use gpv so these
people access
infrastructure outside this infrastructure that is,
in a way to access their ws account
the permissions to access
the data are managed  and the cost term is
associated with their team, so if they
have access to gpu, then, well, for
example, it is really structured or
moderation people, it is to each of the teams
that are in contact that they are
serving with gpu, nothing because they say they
used  p3 and those distances are
extra expensive at several dollars per hour and if
you have been walking all day exactly
then what they are was allowed for the aps
lift the go with gpu so
that you can do your experiments at the
time of training we let you
choose gpu to train why let's
see laws that the team does the
cost-benefit analysis but many
times the gpv has turned on one night
versus the computer turned on 5  o 6
days that it is the responsibility of the teams to
do this type of analysis if a
gpu follows outside this infrastructure and
that is why to add it as a fitur
we have to be careful
about that and how we are going to manage
costs that appear today is not
prepared  to work with those
instances then you have to give them the
capabilities I
answered the question thanks you're welcome
as I have carlos who wanted to know if they
have models this guy
who messes up talks to us if they have models
in parallel doing the same thing they can
decide on what percentages of  a new
model is put online and it is so
multiple with the previous version as they
manage that the working group
decides no longer  This migration is done with
a new model that can have a strong impact on
baby testing. Well, we currently do not have
infrastructure and as a
service to avoid sting. It is one of
the things that we have in the backlog.
Through this, what you can really
do is good if you want to and  texting
of this model with this model
configuring the traffic that you direct to it is
super interesting to do and we want to
do it today some teams
do it to two implement their own
ibi testing strategies because they have
control of the traffic and of the instances and
of the  of the environments then they do it
there are teams that have infrastructure that
is built more
like more advanced to do and test and
others only want it but if it is a
technique that is known a priori it is not
built as a service it is in the
backlog and
clear point when  you stick the apps with the
site display this image you have
different diploma strategies in
canary blue green all in the
infrastructure  structure you have but this is
replicated to you they begin to derive traffic
with twice as much citic it works well then it
reacts pays it and little by little it is
adding to you is this total that he with
box work infrastructure for
microservices and for
traditional web applications is  that is
automated it is great but
the vitesse team does not exist
and for us it would be basic or
great to have it so it is one of the things
that we want to see it contributes
but as eyes
[Laughs]
you wonder if it can be for the
two of us to pee that ends  generating be the
pint that runs the model and the strange one
that publishes it to the outside that you are
using to be yours the baby python
and that you are using des albères and says
there is a director one extra thing well the
applications that we have to build to
the must  get to this serbian of
applications then it is when in
yuri I say I want to make an application to
choose the technology and it gives you a boiler
plate for the case of payton you  generates
a pep mason and unique boiler we
made some improvements this year and now
we can choose between whether unique or wv cg and
you provide the configuration at that level
the gentiles are outside they are in
the infra layer let's say in this case
for the fair  it's the same now he after
handling the traffic from the app from the
serving to the
to the defined one
don't be merciful I know we only
work attention applications ok and
inside the day beyond the sun of
single art at the point that is the one he wants
this mosquito a lot of flash that a
lot of flash that there are some like
nasty who are wanting to experiment
with me and I don't know how much and all
the zinc brakes that as always in
this type of discussion
from the technology point of view we want to
optimize everything but what part  of the
business so as long as we can
respond in time, it is that I have not
left it nástic it is a lot of flash and
for when business logic is needed
or I put for a day  a not what
it really is because what it says appears
and it is voice we give there have been applications
then from then on everything for
within for our
thanks
ask ask they
have some maxilla in congo
imagine as soon as in go that is some
interaction between what they are  doing
in machine line and then the web they want
some
only at the level of desert bing that is
the application on this side that you are going
to boil is they communicate via http
then in mail and if you are using it a lot
and generally when you do when
it makes sense to use something we favor something
to execute the models the machine that
executes the spanish model
so we are using it only for
business logic and consuming the
model as a service that is the hit
to the exact lask in two
different instances microservices out what is
a  little what we are trying to do with this
is that the rest of the free market
understands the models as a service
plus they ask for a database and base
of data you access it with a client and
that's it and since we want them the
ghana model as well as a rest interface that
they with a stick a jason get
a prediction and it is to deploy models to
stick to services then this side
is used a lot by
you  It has the table where they have as
the tracking of the models they use some
tool type e-mail flow to swallow
as metrics of the models I do not use
this custom of liberators the first
if until now
what we are going to start doing in
terms of monitoring is
against infrastructure and give
developers the option that if they stick
to certain interfaces that have types of
messages of all kinds of formats,
we will be able to provide them with
monitoring files on top of that and who does not
follow that interface is the same to
execute their model  without accessing the
file in terms of
prefabricated things to do more in learning
in the training stage for
sending and we use 6 maker which is a
being  amazon vice for but then
everything we are building in
some way competed with 6 maker it
helped us to quickly have access to
infrastructure and some
specific things but as a product amazon did
not have it very developed to 6 may care
in fact it had python 34 put on it
as the only option something like this to payton
27 and we said that we want to see 6 medicare
and they put 35 to go we said everything is
fine but I want all the python
and joaquín we said let's go for more because
because we just have a
big dam so we have people who
can take care of it  to do this
orchestration and say raise an
instance install monitor the
specific run registered with a yankee the
great results can be in a
small company in an SME or in a startup and
well probably if it makes much more
sense to stick to these
cloud flows in terms  of costs and
analyze them I always
answered when asked I went the other way
thanks
like this March-April-  may
you are michael was there where it says a n
a little circle a s 3 don't throw me
down the pyramid tape in lobito 6 may
care
was what was used to train
with respect to October the issue
of data security and account  from something
implemented within fiber or that is
handled directly with the people who
own the data lakes to another other
good security
is key and there is at most a lot then
it is not by our side
and the IT security people
work hand
in hand  In terms of access to data,
each microservice can somehow
transform a data source,
so there are security issues that
apply to all of us, we have a measure of this
email, there are initiatives for the
largest flows of information and
more and longer life  of the free market,
so there are teams dedicated to
managing these data sets, these
data tracks, they manage the data
, they give us tools to access, for
example, Jaime as a platform  orma to make a
query based on hadoop or things
like that and then they are also in charge
of managing permissions,
one of which is difficult to express, but
one of the biggest advantages of working
with this is that there are actually people
in charge of that one  it is
asking permissions well and in general
everything that does not adapt sensitively is
easy to exceed which is great
based on the sensitive attack or there are
obviously sections of
information that are not easy to access and it is also necessary to
understand that when one in a  model
as something ends up making information
so there is no need to put information,
that is, from a model all this is
the securitization of data models
is given behind
infrastructure
the last question hello I wanted to
ask you if they want to ask you if they have
had  to work with an algorithm that
requires training in real time and
if that happened as an over, it was seen
how they fitted it into this training  training
and time as continuously in
training and in key deployments we
wanted to have a ritual that
allows you to see if you how your algorithm has to
behave in the next prediction
basically after we are going to talk
talk to another just who are standing
with the a  Let's see if we have any use cases
of those, let's see what I can say about
daily club feedback,
but it's something smaller than that, I don't know
in the field of applications
that we can talk about it, let's see an example